she will tell us I know she'll explain
us asunder like a spritzer thank you
so this is a little bit of a merge talk
from the things which were announced
initially for Alex my and myself so I
hope we didn't compress it down too far
so we have seen coats already coming up
a few times also involved in distance
coding and so on and I was thinking of
even leaving some of the pictures that
Daniela drew because the pictures we
draw for code based script are very
similar to the pictures that we draw for
lettuce based cryptography now one
difference is and I've only gonna cover
binary codes today is that for us
everything is discrete there are no
gorshins running around there is no a
little bit away from it it's either this
or that zero one and so we're looking
after net parity check matrices and so
one of the representations of our codes
or one of the ways to define whether
something is in the code is by design
saying does it satisfy a certain number
of checks so here's a very easy example
of a Hamming code our code words gonna
be strings in this case of length seven
so there are seven positions here and if
you have something which got transmitted
without being exposed to any noise then
the string of seven positions will
satisfy all these three check equations
so just to say what we mean by this it's
basically a vector times matrix
multiplication I'm thinking of my
vectors as column vectors but that
messes up the slides so if I need to
write them out it's a it's a horizontal
thing but I thing I don't want to put
transposes anywhere so please forgive me
for not putting T's everywhere and
ninety degree flip your vectors as
appropriate so this thing would normally
be a vertical thingy
okay so then this first line is just
we're adding the first two not the third
and then the so then this position in
this position we always start counting
zero and so we're getting this nice
scheme matching the matrix and if you
find any error somewhere like if one of
the bits will flip then these one of the
color all of these equations will not
hold so I promise to you it was only one
bit that got flipped and we've seen that
the first equation doesn't hold the
second does and the third doesn't so we
have an error pattern nobody would call
the syndrome of 1 0 1 and so ok it's
just seven positions so we can run
through them and test all of them or you
can also just look because I wrote them
in kind of a obvious representation so
if the first and the second if the first
and the third are wrong the second one
is fine then I guess you're looking at
this position that yes indeed b1 is the
one that got flipped and of course if it
was more errors if you have two
positions that are wrong you could for
have for instance have that the b6 is
wrong and before is wrong you would see
the same pattern but we always assume
that fewer errors are more likely so if
one error gives this pattern then we
assume this one error happened now of
course we're looking at much much bigger
matrices but then they don't fit on the
slide and or gets kind of messy so I
wanted to give one nice example here
also need to fix some notation so the
length is normally called n so that's
just how many bits are in our code word
we distinguish between words that are in
the code so that satisfy this parity
check equations and things which arrive
so that have gotten an error after so
they I will try to say vector or
received word because this is the code
word plus some extra e LG Bradley we
just added something well 0 1 0 0 in our
example and then this matrix well it
gives you a number of equations so it
kind of restricts how many of those two
to the N words actual code words and so
in the case that we have full rank if
you have n minus K equations you're
getting a code of dimension K that means
there are 2 to the K words that satisfy
it because we have n minus K
restrictions
yes the sun's artificial why don't I say
I have K restrictions that's just
historically coming from coding theory
that we give a nice name to the
dimension and then the number of
equations has to deal with a minus in it
also in cryptography when you're dealing
with these codes because these matrices
because those gonna be our public keys
in the end there's some redundancy in
them we can add those rows and do
Gaussian elimination on those and we're
getting the same restrictions so we
often like to restrict them such that I
mean represent them such that the end of
this is an identity matrix now that
doesn't always work but it since it's
nice for compacta fiying you basically I
mean in this example it looks like
you're saving half and if you have more
extreme choices between your N minus K n
minus K and your n you might actually
save a lot more a lot less and so we
like to put them into what we call
systematic form which means there's an
identity matrix on the right and if
you're reading other books is on the
left but well ok somewhere and then we
ignore this and tell our crypto system
well you implicitly know that there is
just as extra matrix now coding theory
has been studied for a I put in 65 years
I could probably put a few extra so
around 70 years of coding theory the
main target was finding nice codes where
nice codes means codes which we can
efficiently decode if somebody sends us
this X plus e by this this received
words which is not the real thing how
can we efficiently figure out where the
errors were and then correct the errors
get the word back but there also are
some theoretical results which say well
you can't just hope that this always
works so if you have a random code then
there's a result that even deciding
whether there is a codeword getting a
vector and deciding whether there is a
codeword in a given distance that is
np-hard now of course we know that NP
hardness doesn't really mean anything
for cryptography but this is still in
the world of coding theory what coding
theory
have done finding nice coats but also
figuring out results yes question yes
the typical statement is that if you
have a code which doesn't have any
structure if you have any of those nice
codes then you are definitely in a area
we have efficient decoding and so then
the what they proved is a worst case
statement that is correct
and we believe that this holds for
random codes and then when mcLeese came
up with his crypto system back in the
70s it's fairly early he noticed that
there is a distinction between the
random case or the worst case you're
right it's worst case with all but there
are
there are some results on average cases
as well but I'm out of my depth though I
don't know
so what mcLeese is saying is use this
distinction between nice codes that we
have and random codes to build a crypto
system out of it now I gotta show you
not the original medleys system I gonna
show you the version of Niederreiter
which is fitting into the system off of
parity check matrices the one thing
which is nasty about Niederreiter is
that it's not as easy to understand how
you encrypt messages but nowadays we
don't want to encrypt messages we doing
a hybrid encryption so where you just
encryption encrypting winding strings
which we want to use for symmetric
crypto so that is easier but
historically what mcLeese saw was this
there is a complexity difference between
those two and my computer tells me I'm
speaking too slowly so let's go for the
next slide that was me
okay so 78 meckley so it was its
perspective 76 was just different
Hellman 77 was RSA so this is really in
the early days of public key
cryptography where people toying around
with hey what is my favorite hardness
assumption what is my area of research
number theory or coding theory or
whatever and can you build something
surprising enough this mclees paper just
got published as a technical report and
never made it into any other literature
we don't really have much details it's
just a very short paper he doesn't
really justify his choices he picks a
very particular code family due to Coppa
which okay was very fashionable at that
point had come out just a few years
earlier but he doesn't really say why he
picks these codes it is one of those
mysteries that I still have is figuring
out like did he try others and could
break it or did he just like this one I
mean proper codes are nice they're
efficient accountable they're also many
of those codes that's also a nice
feature of them but that still doesn't
justify picking them over some others
which turned out to be pretty broken now
he posts some parameters and in his
paper he says this is for 2060 for
security
and that's one of the things we'll find
very remarkable of the mcLeese system is
that the predictions of the hardness
have held up really really well over
many many years of work it felt a little
bit cruel to break a thirty-year crypto
system and go now
ruff we got you because I mean 30 years
later you have a ton more computational
speed
I mean 19 2008 when we finally was a few
friends put together some clusters and
broke those parameters it was not by
smartness was mostly by advances in
computing that we could broke it and
okay there were two to the 60 cycles not
to the 64 but it's it's very close if
you look at like the initial parameters
for RSA they were missing a lot of big
complexity steps that happened and was
mcLeese his parameter choices were
pretty good and have held up well if you
look at what he had known as in what
attacks do we have that decode generic
codes there was a 1962 paper by print
I'll get to that a bit later for the
details and that was basically what was
guiding his analysis of how long it
should take to break this and when you
look at the main constants so if you
want to have something which has
albert's of security so takes to the
algebraic then the complex the key size
grows was the main constant here and
then has some low order terms in the
little of one here and this see zero
back for the parameter tag is 0.7 for
something okay so that tells you how you
choose your keys and then or allocate
you can still lose a few bits of
security of course the o of one matters
a lot
when you're making concrete choices but
it's interesting to see how the scaling
works and then comes a whole bunch of
security analysis so even though it was
to take just two taking the report CODIS
here is like the system and went ahead
we're like hey well now that you have
your concrete target how can we do this
more efficiently I mean for for
complexity theory once you know it's
exponential time you kind of stop caring
but if it's a crypto system you want to
know what is this exponent how long does
it take in our shave off a little bit
even if I can shave off constants or
one pieces at slot and so there's a
bunch of analysis some I put post
quantum so those are considering quanta
cover analysis of these systems it is
the minority on the other hand well it
helps to have a whole bunch of
literature developed to then turn into
quantum algorithms so dense initial
paper there is taking basic the print
algorithm and then cartilage and Elena
are taking the more advanced algorithms
that happened afterwards from historical
perspective I find it very interesting
that all of this work forty years of
work quite a few papers or if I take
branch in the counter can even claim
it's more than that but let's say forty
years it's almost sixty they can't the
constant in this he size estimate the
main constant not a little of one there
was lots of changes in at of one but the
consensus is same 0.74 so there have
been a lot of work they've been analysis
all of those papers totally deserve to
be published and there are some which
have changed the little o of one that
some which are just like optimizing in
smaller notions I mean when we did the
extra crypt analysis when we put the
computers to work we optimize every
constants we could no question but it
didn't do much harm on theirs on topics
so if you want to achieve frequency
security or post quant security of
certain sizes then okay we basically
know what to do but you also know
understand why the system is not quite
as popular as ours a these numbers are a
little bit large so if you can have RSA
which for frequency QD gives you say on
the 28 bits and you're in this range
you're just dealing with 3072 bits and
this is a quarter of a kilo of a
megabyte there's a big difference here
and the main difference of the reasons
why the keys are so big is that we're
dealing with these matrices so there is
as lambda square so if you want to
increase the lambda everyone who's a
security level we're increasing it in
both directions were increasing it in
the end direction and in the N minus K
direction and so we get a quadratic
growth and that means that the keys are
inconvenient occurs
inconveniently big on the other hand if
you have a system where you basically
give your public key to somebody wants
and you really trust this public key
because well has gotten 40 years of
couple analysis it doesn't really matter
how big this key is I mean a megabyte of
storage on your hard disk is close to
nothing and even if you occasionally
want to update this key it's not too bad
what we're proposing for long-term
security is a megabyte so you feel that
but then what happens with post quantum
so I mentioned three papers with quantum
analysis growver does a screwed on the
simplest attack and less than a screwed
on the more advanced attacks so
basically similar to symmetric
cryptography
we have a good handle as at our current
knowledge and I mean in this workshop
we're encouraging more people to look
into this so if you can break this
here's a nice and juicy target this is
something where at this moment I would
say it's the encryption system where I
have the highest trust so I feel like
okay if something happened I would be
really surprised so please go ahead
alright so this was the advertisement
part of the system of the talk let's go
back to actually teaching some stuff so
I mentioned the decoding problem before
I mentioned T and P hardness result and
so there are two views on on this
decoding so the normal thing is you have
your code word that is sending and some
of the positions flip so then you have
what we call the decoding problem often
enough somebody tells you what the
weight is in our crypto systems we will
know for sure what the weight of this
edit code word is going to be of this
extra error is going to be also notional
notations so we talked about the
Hemingway tour Hamming distance so
hemming weight is the number of nonzero
positions Hamming distance is the number
of positions where two vectors differ
so unlike lettuces our errors are
discreet so it's either there is an
error or there is not an error so we're
just counting how many they are and so
then we take something which is T steps
away from a codeword well okay in each
coordinate I can go one away
I flip from a zero to a one over one two
zero and then nice families where we can
decode efficiently I going to briefly
show copper codes here but if you're
taking a course in coding Theory first
gonna see BCH codes you're gonna see you
read Solomon codes and then you're gonna
see more advanced for the best attacks
that we have generically that work if we
don't know anything about the code if it
see randomly chosen matrix doesn't have
any structure then we have some
exponential time attacks algorithms in
this case and then for some of those we
have structural attacks so it has to
take into account how the code is
generated and can actually see through
whatever perturbations we put there one
last thing on the decoding I mean I
showed you the parity check matrix and
so you can also see the decoding problem
as is syndrome decoding so syndrome is
the output of computing H times this
vector if this X was a code word then
all parity checks are satisfied so the
syndrome is 0 if the syndrome is nonzero
we know an error has occurred but the
weight of the syndrome doesn't give us
any indication of how many errors have
occurred because that's just the sum of
the columns of age where we have some
errors and the columns of H can be
fairly dense so even if there's just one
error while we see one of the columns
remember we saw the one zero one example
before was just one error but it had two
thirds of the bit set and so you can ask
asked hey if I have e syndrome decoder
is that better or worse than having a
general decoder so syndrome decoder is
something which takes this s and outputs
an error vector and the gen normal
decoder is something which takes the
erroneous vector and outputs the error
well those two iquivalent I've been
leaving the slide up long enough so I
hope you have started thinking about it
if you have a syndrome decoder and you
have received a erroneous codeword well
you can just compute the syndrome that's
the easy direction you take your thing
you X you multiply by H you're getting a
syndrome use the syndrome decoder you're
getting your error vector and then you
add X
and the error and you getting the fixed
code word now the other way around if
you only have a generic decoder but
you're only giving a syndrome which is
much shorter you have this n minus K
bits
how can you expand this to something
which has the full length and before
we're saying hey can we find something
which maps to it so am I asking you now
to solve this allegedly hard problem
finding earth a pre-image of the
syndrome ok so first of all I'm doing
the easy case again I assume systematic
form in this case well you can put the
identity in whatever subpods doesn't
matter simply to present this way now if
I have the identity in those positions
then it's easy to find one vector which
maps to s namely I putting zeroes in the
part of Q this is an N minus K so that's
as wide or as high as my syndrome is and
I putting the syndrome here now this
vector times H well again remember I'm
writing my things this is a column
vector in principle so I have zeros
multiplied by Q and then s multiplied by
the identity matrix so of course I'm
getting s so this is a vector which maps
to s but this is normally not a solution
to my decoding problem because my
decoding problem says I want to find a
low weight vector I want to find
something which has very few entries
that are nonzero ok there are lots of
zeros here
I have K zeros here but they're probably
way too many non-zeroes in this ass I've
having n minus K positions there and the
number of errors I'm looking for is
typically much lower than a random
aspect I would have I mean it could
happen that it's the right thing but
typically it's not ok so neither ITER or
e promised it would come so neither Ida
says let's take a code that we can
nicely decode and take the parity check
matrix of that and then do some stuff
and this is work analysis has to look
whether this is actually secure but
trying to perturb this nice hearty check
matrix with other matrices to come out
to something which looks much more
generic so this is where things can go
wrong this go has gone wrong for some
codes including the one from
Niederreiter system that he originally
proposed because these steps might not
hide the structure well enough but let's
be optimistic for a moment just explain
how the system work in the sense of well
we can encrypt and decrypt and then
worry about how attacks can work so what
we do is we take our nice parity check
matrix H here and we multiply from left
and right with two matrices now we want
to preserve the rank and so on so these
have to be invertible but we need to
have more restrictions on the one on the
right here this P has to be a
permutation matrix so permutation matrix
is the matrix which has per row exactly
one one and per column exactly one one
and that means it just shifts like if
you multiply a vector by it it just
shifts or permutes the positions between
those so most importantly if you take
for instance our error vector e and
multiply it by this it will not increase
the weight so permutation matrix just
swaps around the positions but doesn't
change the weight of it and this s is a
general invertible matrix so there we
have a lot of choices and then the
public key is going to be this matrix K
so the product s times H times P where K
is giving away all the informations
given away all the information and then
P and s are there to protect that to
encrypt and this was when you'd write as
a little clunky but just think of you
sending a random message so you don't
have to worry about this encoding he
says he can only encrypt messages which
have exactly weighted T so in a CEM
scenario or any hybrid encryption
scenario where sending your a s key what
you do is you pick a random key of
weight T and then you look back you can
actually find complicated algorithms
which turn
string and you calculate how big the
message space is and you pick one of
those strings and turn this into a
string which has exactly that weight but
we don't have to bother with us because
we don't typically about it okay so the
encryption is very simple we just take
this public key multiplied by this
vector and we're getting a syndrome nice
feature of Niederreiter
which is why I'm presenting this over
mcLeese is that the ciphertext is
actually very nice and short it is just
the height of the matrix not the length
of the matrix so what Meg Lee's
initially had done was something with
the code words were the full length and
Niederreiter had this nice idea of
saying hey if you have the syndrome we
can do the same and then it's just a
little clunky on the encryption part on
the encoding part and then the
decryption so what the attacker is faced
with is to find some II which has the
right weight and that typically is only
one so find the vector that the
encryption was putting in there so if
you have a passive attacker so somebody
was not messing you feeding you other
stuff and so on then his face was
exactly the key error decoding problem
in the syndrome version but we know now
it's the same as the other one okay it's
nice that the attacker can't decode but
can we still decode it's kind of helpful
for crypto system if it actually can't
that get the message back okay now can
we come to the part where it was
important how we shows these pieces so
remember that K the public key was a
general invertible matrix times H times
a permutation matrix and we're now given
this thing now we are the legitimate is
recipient so we know all the matrices in
there so we know P we know s so for now
I'm not wearing my tag head but I'm
wearing my user head so I can just take
this s and invert it because I have it
and probably I want to actually store as
inverse because that's what I'm using
afterwards okay if I mod if I left
multiply the syndrome by this then well
this just cancels the s here so that's
nice and then left with hpe and I'm
using that P times e well piece just the
permutation matrix so P times e has the
same weight
he has itself and we have chosen a code
which we can efficiently decode and okay
we should have chosen the T so that we
can efficiently decode T errors and so
we're getting PE instead of E but piece
of permutation matrix and we know this
so at this moment we use our efficient
decoding algorithm here we use our
secret knowledge of how to efficiently
decode this code represented by H which
is hidden in the code represented by K
and then the last step okay we unfirm
ute this vector so we just multiply by P
inverse and we getting the error vector
then we getting back to the error that
actually the sender had put in there and
then either continue in the same hybrid
way so do the same as a sender hashes
and turned in a s key or in the original
Niederreiter
well this would be the message already
that's what have any teeth okay so T is
a system parameter so people who work in
this system they know how long the code
is N and K is also fixed and T is also
fixed so everybody will shoes codes in a
certain family and I haven't told you
anything yet about this family so far
you could think okay the family is of
one so how much secrecy is there we're
actually going to look at a family where
there's a lot of choices for H for the
same parameters n K and T so we're going
to put in those three things and I gonna
show you e huge family of codes that are
all equally good but yes you do want
some you're picking your code so that
you can efficiently co-chairs and if you
don't have many errors well the job of
the attacker will get harder with more
errors so if you at best can correct
five errors then if you're thinking of
like brute force attack you have this
expanded word and you know five of those
positions then okay you're basically
picking and choose five try all of them
so I have an Ncube attack
so T has to be sufficiently large and
has to be sufficiently large that this n
to the T attack it's less I mean n chose
cheese is less than n to the T but for
for smaller is the best approximation
that this thing does not actually break
it so you want to have codes which have
sufficiently many errors to give you a
concrete example what what mcLeese had
in his original paper was n being 1024
okay being 524 and T being 50 so there
were 50 errors added to a thousand bit
word just for four sizes and now we're
going for something three thousand four
in and hundred something for the number
of errors so it's not it's not huge the
key size really comes from well it's
three thousand this way and that wasn't
five hundred that way okay so coats
nicely this over to this
so what make least proposed was using
copper codes and those I've been holding
up very well what then neither Ida
proposed was doing Reed Solomon codes
and they got broken just a few years
later by a stick often sadhana cough
showing that there's too much structure
in this cause it's a too restricted
family and you can see in this K in the
public key you can't figure out what the
code was that was put in there so if you
can't find that then it's game over
there are more corpses in the way I mean
coding serious once we talk to them
going like hey look can we have your
nicest killed then they come with an
Isis code and then we said well that
wasn't good enough it's it's sometimes I
would see seeing smiles of a coding
theorist over there so it is unclear
what makes a code good but we have seen
some codes which were not good where the
structure was too strong and in the end
just means people have to look at those
codes for a long time to see what they
can't see anything and nicely enough
copper codes were proposed in the first
and have been considered for the whole
time so we're still very happy with
those but rinses in this competition has
several mouthful quasi cyclic medium
density parity check
I'm not gonna write this out on the
slide else I'm running overflow so this
appeared on a talk well yesterday but it
was a different workshop so you have a
parity check matrixes H which has medium
density and then you have other decoding
algorithms and quasi cyclic means that
your code doesn't need the full two
dimensional thing to be represented but
you have a structure where the first row
with its cyclic shifts tells you the
parts under it and then quasi cyclic
means there's this part with the shifts
there's this part with the shifts and
there can be a third part if you want
all the rank metric coats and then it's
competition I seen a talk about it at a
actual workshop and I was very happy
that now the paper is announced but I
still couldn't find it so I don't know
where this has gotten worse or better
and I mean they take at worst so I'm
writing some scratches because I haven't
seen it but this paper will be at your
Crypt
so there is some progress on a different
type of codes I'm just talking about
linear codes with Hamming metric and
there is something else called rank
metric codes in the NIST competition and
they have gotten a little bit of a hit
alright so security notions so what we
want to achieve is a one-way encryption
system the systems are presented so far
I said School Board version so these are
not CCA secure so you do want to throw
on it some transform for encryption or
well you probably want to go for a CEM
dam version so don't bother with e
encoding so what we typically do is we
pick for Niederreiter a random a of the
right weight then use the hash office
for a s and we also make sure to
authenticate and their interests and
Fugees our code on it or some rien
corruption so things to make sure that
nobody can send us slightly wrong code
words because if somebody has the power
to send e code words and see how you
react they could figure out whether it's
the right distance away and basically
comment orally extract from you is this
a position with an error or not so if
you don't put the transforms on there
there are lots of active attacks that
well it's not good then they see kind of
the total logical result is if you can
break the one-wayness you can
either distinguish the key for random
and that's why I'm tamya coming back to
your question from before I know that
the result here is from random and so I
need to look which reduction they're
using which np-hardness statement
they're doing there because it says from
random and not from the worst case
because that would be kind of a bad one
and then what we normally look for is
can we actually break one-wayness for a
particular given key and then our text
we distinguish into two categories we
have the generic attacks and that's what
I'm going to speak about in the next few
minutes so that's information set
decoding so those attacks work for any
code they work for the ugly case at the
case of K that we hope we are presenting
our attacker with but then there's also
structural attacks those are attacks
which are trying to find what code have
a put in there what nice decoding
algorithm am i hiding in my K so this is
where on the previous slide I was saying
we have these corpses so for instance
there was these Gabby Doolin codes which
had a very nice structure with not
binary codes but like subfields so you
had a FP and you had a FP to the N and
he could basically figure out how the
Frobenius would be acting on pieces and
you could still see this on the K level
even though it was totally messing up
the field structure you could piece
together which are kind of the pieces in
the subfields in the extension field for
such special decoding attacks so there
group no bases have been shown to be
quite efficient now of course you might
think hey group no basis is quite a big
hammer but if you're trying to find e
both the structure there were some where
this this helped so it was not as like
governor bases with full size n and then
for the generic attacks well let me flip
to the next slide for that oh yeah
what basis you mean okay so that depends
on how you want to use a group no basis
I take I'm thinking of the algebraic
geometry attacks for instance that you
could use coconut vices so I'm really
thinking structural attacks where you're
having a family of codes in there for
instance you're having like elliptic
curve codes or emission codes
nothing of any of the papers that is
trying that and I also
I mean you would have to I mean not
having enough equation you can always
think of bootstrapping so that Percy is
not yeah but here I think they cancel
out so maybe that's yeah so so I was
thinking of compromise is really just
for for structural attacks it because I
haven't seen anywhere for you for
generic okay so I was hiding before like
how would you do a brute-force attack I
was giving you this example with the end
positions and just forever in length and
five positions so in general if I tell
you hey T of the positions are an error
then you would say well you're picking
randomly T columns of this see whether
those add up to the syndrome you've
received if yes you win if no well try
the next there are lots of those there
are as I said and choose T such columns
so it's you can say okay it's n choose T
full matrix computations each time
taking well the sum or you can do this
like basically swap in swap out
something so out so you can bring it
down to most of the time there's the
cost of one extra addition but that's
still a lot so here trying to figure out
the positions but at the same time and
you think about it
when you're trying to figure out a
position we're also trying to figure out
the non positions so we're kind of
fixing both of those and the pram geotag
is better in that it says hey let's just
figure out some non positions soap
wrench the original information said
decoding attack is saying let's go for
easy setup let's assume there is no
error over here and only errors over
here well then we can very easily read
off what our syndrome should be it
should be just this Plus this Plus this
Plus this so if our syndrome has just
wait T then we're done in the same way
that I said before we can turn e
syndrome decoder sorry a syndrome
decoding problem into a generic decoding
problem by well expending the
Zero's but normally our syndrome doesn't
have YT and normally we don't have our
matrix or our arrangement so that all
all errors over here and none of the
errors over here but what Panchen
observed is hey we can't do this we
can't randomly swap around columns the
same way that in the brute-force attack
you're picking columns well that's the
same as moving columns left and right
and so what he's doing is we permuting
que meaning we're permuting these
positions and yes there's a ton of
positions if you're picking the left
side or the right side well it's always
n minus K or K of those and then you do
systematic form if that fails try again
if it doesn't fail then stuff here we
will win if all the errors are over here
and none of the errors is over here so
we can find out from the new syndrome
whether we have succeeded now how do we
update our syndrome how do we get into
the syndrome that matches this thing
under on the permute matrix well what we
have done with steps is we've applied
basically two matrices we have done a
permutation that was the initial thing
swapping things left and right and we've
applied an invertible matrix you in the
Gauss elimination when we got to
systematic form okay so if that's our K
prime then our s Prime has to go through
the same transformations well the the P
doesn't apply to s but the you would
apply to s as well so we updating s to u
times s and if we are correct that all
the errors are over here and none of the
errors is over here then the zu times s
will have the right weight if that's
correct then we know what the vector
looks like then we have found an e prime
which fits this and then we need to
unpermitted to get the positions and y
places
so this is the mother of all information
set decoding attack so let me spend a
moment longer on on going through this
inset off in the brute force way be
figuring out I mean we are forcing all
the positions of the errors and all the
positions of the non errors here we're
having a much better chance because
we're only saying well it's a left-right
split but we're leaving the error a lot
of range here we only restricting the
error to being somewhere in these n
minus K positions but we don't have to
fix it we don't have to be exactly right
so the cost of this thing when do we
succeed
well we succeed if the permutation gets
us such that of all the N choose T
different position that we can have we
have restricted to error the error to
just n minus K over T so how many times
do you have to repeat this that means we
win in the case that we have n minus K
over T so if the errors are over here
out of all the positions are of M chose
T now this is a very simple algorithm
and simple algorithm is nice in this
case because we can also see how to turn
this into a quantum attack we're looking
for something which gives the right
weight I mean you have to do turn off
this into a computational into a circuit
and so on but you're basically getting a
screwed on the whole thing leaving out
constants here the constants do include
something for the probability that this
thing can actually be put into a
systematic form so only about 1/3 of all
matrices work so you have another
constant sitting around there but oh of
something just gives you a score
speed-up I mean the constants are the
same in in both classical and quantum
0.29 then one more attack which I going
to go through in detail to show how
things get more complicated but then we
also need more storage is Libre Kell who
said ok we're doing the same as branch
again we doing this permutation thing
systematic form updating
yes that's the same like the permutation
the you applied this to here and then we
turned this into a search problem by
saying well we allow a few of the errors
on that side there we need to do a brute
force search but I'll probably build he
will get better because we allowing say
two errors over here and then all about
two errors over here now our check gets
more expensive we need to check through
all the positions on the left and then
check whether well for those positions
this thing here has the right weight
Namie well in this case - or in general
P of those can be off and then well we
unpermitted whatever comes around so
what is the cost now so we now have the
improvement factor here that we don't
have to have all the P here so we're
having a Katia's P for the key positions
on the left and we have a tea shoes t
minus n minus K shoes t minus P on the
right so this is bigger so the cost goes
down compared to before but we also have
the brute force search over on this part
maybe trying to combine all the
combinations and check them ok and then
comes a whole bunch more text where
you're improving what you're looking
like you don't look at all positions and
so on once you're here then you have to
figure out where do you apply your
Grover and how do you handle drove of
its storage you can do it so the
improvements that are normally assume
that you have stars sitting around
because you're trying to find something
that maps to a certain target on there
so then Leon is saying hey we can't make
this cheap about only checking on
certain positions Stern is turning this
into a collision search problem on here
and then further papers are improving in
here that you don't have to go all the
way down or
that you can skip some part here so at
the moment we are having some regions
where you're not allowed to have any
errors these green lines won't be
allowed to have errors which gets too
restrictive for large parameters so
these then have quantum speedups which
are less than screwed of the whole thing
I promised you to show briefly how these
codes are chosen to convince you that
there are many of them so very quick one
slide thing what is a binary copper code
okay so the freedom that we have is as
follows we're picking a power of two
well there's a parameter M which comes
in and then we over this bigger field
over f2 to the M we're picking a
polynomial which must be square free we
typically choose it to be irreducible
even definitely guaranteed to be square
free and this polynomial has degree T so
this is the same T that we're gonna use
later on as number of errors so we can
totally figure out how many errors we
want to compute how many errors want to
add or be able to correct by having this
parameter T now he must not be zero for
any of the positions in this larger
field well actually just in this list
but if you pick your polynomial to be
irreducible then you're very sure it
doesn't have any roots so that's a very
simple thing this list here will be
different elements of the final field F
2 to the M so the length is bounded by
the number of elements in there and okay
our tech will get more expensive the
larger n is so okay your M has to be
sufficiently large so typically what
you're seeing is powers of two running
around and then this is either the full
thing or a subset of it this is called
the support of the code and then that's
the code isn't beautiful
okay you can look that this is actually
linear by saying well if you add two of
those code words meaning two of those
things satisfy the same equation and
also their sample satisfied because well
it's linear in the pieces so yep it is a
code it's not the normal description
they used to it doesn't give you a big
parity check matrix doesn't give you
generator matrix of course you can cover
or recover a parity check matrix from
this thing it's not at a hard problem
the dimension typically if everything is
full ring and so on so there's a bound
but typically we're seeing full rank in
our examples so n minus n times T is
this K and the distance is 2 T plus 1 so
that's the same error that shall be d
the distance D is larger than 2 T plus 1
that would be otherwise well strange
okay so they are many of those family
many of those codes I can pick any
polynomial of degree team even if I just
restrict to irreducible and then I can
also rearrange the support now the last
part doesn't give much information but
it still gives me well I mean if I have
a fixed ordering in mind I can test it
this I showed you before about how these
codes belong together a nice thing about
GABA codes is that I can actually skip
most of these things by saying oh the
permutation is just the different
rearrangements of the different field
elements so I don't actually need to
pick a P extra it is already in my
choice of code so I don't have to
remember this big matrix P it's just a
different ordering of the field elements
that I have to remember and then turning
something into systematic form
implicitly gives you a matrix so you
also don't need to remember it so you
don't actually need any of the P and s
stuff that I showed for random codes or
general case for global codes all you
need to remember is which ordering of
the field elements that you have and
what polynomial did you pick and then
you have a nice efficient decoding
algorithm to to become messy
which does that somebody has
attack paper on support splitting so if
you want to figure out whether the code
that you have found is actually the
correct code then that part is
sufficient at least for all observers
cases it runs in polynomial time there
are some I mean not for every code it
must but at least for copper codes it's
believed and there are some good
indication that it always will be so
support splitting it says it computes
code equivalents for copper codes so you
giving a Canada copper code and the
public key and then the supports we are
splitting algorithm officially answers
saying is this the same or not
however they are a ton of copper codes
so even if you have an efficient test
for this you run it exponentially many
times and so this part is not the hard
part this sir the number of codes is
sufficient and then that's it for me to
say I have one last slides with
advertisement
thank you for your memory
time is a Atlantic at least it seems
like all these others and by exponential
time memory no stone yet so stone and
follow-up algorithms including some ways
with Alex my those use a lot of memory
as well so on the on the left part
there's no distinction like yeah there's
a world separation for codes in a
similar way so I mean so what what
escaped is all the tuning of parameters
you typically expect expecting some
exponential also in the storage and so I
mean when we did the attack it was in
the exponential land but small enough to
fit so you two new parameters to fit
this on the theory side I'm not aware of
the separation
[Applause]